oh hello there I didn't see you come in
this is Matt Damon I'm in a fake bar
drinking a fake martini which is just
really water they got my character
confused with James Bond so I'm going to
teach you how to how to win in a movie
fight well I guess here's the thing
about movie fights that you should know
unlike a regular fight where nobody
knows what's gonna happen in a movie
fight everybody knows exactly what's
gonna happen and that's the only way it
can work it's much more like like a
dance
and so as tough is like Hollywood actors
try to pretend they are they're really
more dancers than fighters I'd like to
bring out Jim who's been working at GQ
for 35 years how you doing buddy good
are you this the biggest thing about a
movie fight is that you just can't see
any air between the person getting hit
and the person throwing the punch a real
left hook right now wouldn't work
because the left hook is a punch that
comes that way right even if Jim threw
his head right at the right moment here
throw your chin now right it looks
horrible because you can see all the air
between there so if you were doing
choreography and the cameras were there
and it would called for a left hook
you'd immediately change that to a
straight left which which crosses that
and eliminates that distance right so
Jim when I cross you throw your throw
your chin as if I've punched you no okay
terrible one two three throw your chin
that kind of idea when all the bones
line up in the right way if you align
them like that you can make somebody go
where you want them to go but you would
never really do that in like a movie
fight you kind of suggest it so if I
were doing this with Jim I take his arm
and kind of go like that and let him
take the movement so that he never
really got hurt so like in a movie if he
came at me right and you've got the
breakaway bottle you bottle like that
throw him down and put it to his neck
and if the camera is in the right place
it looks like we actually know what
we're doing how was it it was a little
excessive
yes sugar now we can eat it no with the
little work he could maybe be in the
next Jason Bourne movie Cheers
even though it's incredibly bad luck to
cheers with water which I've just done
la tap water it's drinkable